ich habe frei war übrigens auch sehr
nett von dir dass du mich an der uni
abgelöst hätte dass du dich mit meiner
ex-freundin angefreundet hast jetzt ist
wahrscheinlich dass ich weiß nicht was
zwischen euch passiert ist aber ich
finde carla ziemlich nett ich weiß sie
früher auch richtig nett jetzt hast du
sie nicht mehr was glaubst du ich glaube
jedenfalls dass ritalin er ziemlich nett
findet es kann schon sein
jedenfalls schon geglaubt sie das
fahrrad repariert hatten dabei weiß doch
gar nicht so kaputt da hat sich danach
nicht mehr berliner gemeldet ach weißt
du wie sieht anderes im kopf da denkt
man sein studium
manchmal sollte man sein studium eben
auch nicht ganz vergessen dass das doch
georgia ich habe einfach viel zu tun wie
sah es ganz anders mag hier gerade ein
ausflug für uns das war ein ausflug nach
lasst uns nach bonn fahren
ich muss lernen aber den hat sich doch
schon so richtig gefreut